Hey, I'm Vitis and I'm a senior research
engineer at Hyark on our labs team.
So, at Hyark our labs team is basically
our research and development arm where
we have machine learning researchers who
kind of explore the frontier of AI/ML
uh and figure out ways to apply it to
home building.
Now, because we're in home building and
we're in spatial reasoning, uh
we pretty much end up needing to use a
lot of what's out there in AI. So,
computer vision to scan hand-sketched
floor plans and parse them into our
internal data model,
>> [music]
>> um
reasoning agents to kind of carry the
user through these agentic experiences,
we have custom transformers,
uh we use diffusion models for image
gen, uh and basically a lot of kind of
what's out there in AI/ML uh we end up
needing to use because of the kind of
multidisciplinary
nature of our product.
So, hopefully that video gives you some
idea of the research areas that we focus
on that I've mapped out here.
And that kind of leads us to uh the
problem, which is
in this in this challenge of getting
frontier research into production, uh we
need to start working with
software engineers, let's say platform
engineers, infrastructure engineers,
back-end engineers who are very familiar
with building robust and
production-grade code, but are likely
not familiar with the methodology and
research in computer vision, in training
your own LLMs, uh and even some top
secret uh topics that I can't reveal
here.
Now, you kind of have the flip side
problem with our uh ML researchers who
are very up-to-date with the latest
papers and can uh pull together these
concepts in novel and creative ways to
develop new features,
but they have not really worked as
software engineers typically where
they've been responsible for production
grade
APIs. So,
that's kind of what I want to get into
is this
this handoff, this this baton pass
how do we facilitate that and how do we
do it productively? And we look at this
basically as a systems and process
problem and I want to kind of zero in on
three main focus areas that you can use
to
improve this
the velocity of teams that that are
bringing research into production. So,
the first thing we'll look at is
research legibility. So, let's say you
have a
ML researcher has produced a prototype
concept. How can they map that out and
make it digestible and understandable
for these different software engineers
and product managers who are going to be
jumping into the project.
The second is how to structure your code
base. So, we use a mono repo.
How do you arrange your code and
modularize it so that it's ready to
receive these new prototype concepts and
turn them around and stand them up
quickly. And then the third thing we'll
look at
is basically, you know, making the jump
from a mapped out
proven out research prototype that's
going to be going into this
repo. How do you decompose that
prototype and stand it up on
best practices in software engineering.
So, taking a look at the first step,
there's a really good article that I
that I want to link a blog from the the
pragmatic engineer
where he talks about software
engineering teams as they grow and start
to scale how important it is to write
out technical design documents,
request for comment, whatever you want
to call it, specifications before
building software
as a way to align teams. So, we have a
very analogous document um that we
require from all research prototypes
that we call the research prototype
taxonomy document. So, it's really just
a technical design document from
software engineering uh with some
specific twists
uh that um make it more digestible given
its its nature in machine learning.
So, the first thing in that document, we
use notion for this, but obviously any
written document will work, is that we
start with the kind of domain context
and like what are the domain specific
you know, we're in the architectural
domain and home building. So, what are
these kind of novel ways to represent
data? Maybe it's a party diagram, maybe
it's a graph to to represent the kind of
circulation graph through a home, maybe
it's
embedding models or latent space
representations.
I like to say kind of picture a software
engineer who just we just hired from JP
Morgan. What are the kind of uh specific
lingos and and data representations that
they might need to know before jumping
into this project. The second is kind of
mapping out the business goal, right?
What's the why does solving this problem
matter and what's the value in this ML
tool?
And then the four uh
remaining parts of this document are
pretty kind of conventional software
engineering principles you might see in
a TDD. So,
the type safety, so we'll see later what
our machine learning repo looks like,
but what is the type contract between
our core product repository
and this machine learning repo? How are
those types shared and how do they stay
in sync? Um then kind of mapping out the
the persistence layer. Is there a
database?
Uh this is an area where
uh we think it's probably best
not to have our researcher spend too
much time
in the persistence layer and just map
out how far they got and this is a great
first entry point once we start bringing
in software engineering
help on the project. Uh then kind of
mapping out the the overall system
architecture. Um
is this a workflow? Is this a chaining
of workflows? Are there external LLM
calls? Like what is the anatomy? What is
the kind of taxonomy of this
research prototype?
And lastly, how are we going to merge
this? How are we going to decompose it?
Um and we'll get into that more uh later
as well.
So, going back to these kind of three
levers we can pull, the first is kind of
that research project taxonomy document.
Uh the second I want to get into are how
we structured our code
and how we
serve our existing
uh
features.
So, we basically have a a separate um
repository from our core product repo
and this is uh
all Python based, right? It's all AI ML
stuff
and it's basically a mono repo of
uh cleanly isolated and fully decoupled
microservices.
And so, let's say data-driven entity
prediction is our
custom transformer model. So, that is
able to up to um
kind of grow and be iterated on and be
fully decoupled from a different
research initiative
and it's pretty much a one-to-one
researcher to microservice
ratio.
So, we find that works really well. We
have a kind of gateway that that guards
requests um and it's all in one Docker
Bridge network. So, the core
um consumers our clients in our in our
web application make kind of API calls
to this gateway which then routes them
to the appropriate microservice.
Now,
uh looking a bit closer at these uh
individual microservices,
uh we tend to build them in a pretty
simple layered architecture, right?
There's an API layer, the business logic
and the data layer.
And then we tend to have like some
really um
really cleanly documented specs uh so
that agents can navigate these
repositories and help accelerate our ML
researchers as much as possible.
So, yeah, kind of taking a another way
to look at this layered architecture, we
have kind of the core business logic at
the services layer. Uh that might, you
know, make external
uh LLM calls to to foundation models or
we might need to pull in our own uh
machine learning model weights in CICD.
Then we wrap that business logic with
controllers.
Um then we put API routers around those
and expose them in FastAPI applications.
And each of those microservices is a
standalone application. And like I said
in the last slide, it's not really the
client that makes a direct call to this
microservice. It kind of goes to that uh
gateway first which routes it to the
appropriate microservice.
And then within each of those
microservices um in the root in the root
directory, we have essentially metadata,
build instructions, a Dockerfile on how
to
how to build this application, uh the
the kind of project dependencies, and
then poetry or or UV uh lock files um as
needed.
And then so I'd like to kind of map out
this um anatomical arrangement of our
kind of three microservices that we have
in production.
And we can kind of see these these
trends and and consistent skeletal
backbones of these projects.
Uh and it's very easy to map them out
and make sure that they're growing um
along best practices in software
engineering.
So, that's basically it for our for our
mono repo. We have these kind of
microservices and then
uh sharing
basically like underneath all of that in
the repository, we have some GitHub
actions to to build and deploy our
automated test suites and kind of
linting, formatting, and type checks,
all the stuff you'd you'd kind of
expect. Uh we have some Jupyter
notebooks that run on on Modal for GPU
compute, um as well as some additional
ML studies, but really the way we look
at it is we have this kind of tooling
layer and even this kind of fun CLI, but
these all just support our ML engineers
in bundling up these microservices that
we uh
serve in production.
So, that's kind of the the RPT is the is
the handoff document between an ML
researcher and additional software
engineering uh talent. The mono repo is
is where that um research project is
ultimately going. And then the only
remaining step is, well, how do we get
there, right? How do we jump from one to
two? And the third lever I want to talk
about is the kind of decomposition
uh and PR review plan.
Uh and we look at that really as a
design problem where we need to kind of
um
figure out how to slice and dice a a
large research
uh monolithic prototype. So, here are
just some images of of um an uh
platform-wide agent feature where you
know, we really studied what axes to
slice uh and dice these projects up on,
what that dependency graph would look
like.
And then we use Graphite um for kind of
stack diffs to then uh decompose these
large monolithic prototypes that have
been proven out um and then get the
right eyes on on review to make sure
that these are ready for production.
Uh we really like Graphite because it
allows for asynchronous review, right? I
could be working on a PR all the way up
here while a domain specialist is still
reviewing a different PR. And once we've
kind of decomposed these PRs uh
thoughtfully,
we can start tapping uh subject matter
experts throughout the organization on
the specific slices or
tightly uh decomposed PRs uh that need
to look at.
And so again, there's there's a lot of
overlap between this initial research
project uh taxonomy document where once
we've mapped out these layers, these the
architecture, what kind of persistence
there is in the types, that tends to
inform
uh your decomposition strategy on how to
bring it into the into the mono repo.
So, to wrap things up, I want to revisit
these kind of three focus areas that you
can use to evaluate how well your team
is bringing research into production.
And I want to talk about kind of some
some diagnostic frameworks to understand
if you need to spend a bit more time and
attention in any of these three.
So, in the first step with your research
legibility,
as your team starts to staff
research initiatives with product
people, with software engineers, with AI
engineers, is it obvious where they
should concentrate their efforts? And is
it clear uh what kind of tasks they need
to pluck off to bring this prototype
into production?
If there's ambiguity in there,
you may need to spend some time
revisiting this process.
In step two,
your code repository. As you start
getting ready to
bring prototypes into your production
grade code base,
is it clear where these buckets lie to
put in new code? Are there templates and
existing frameworks and patterns that
you can mimic?
Or is it possible that maybe you've
started to outgrow that code base and
that system architecture, and every time
you bring in new research concepts,
you're fighting these old abstractions
and having headaches from limitations of
your repository.
And then lastly,
in the decomposition phase, are you able
to consistently estimate the timelines
and delivery dates for moving research
concepts into your repository?
Is it clear which subject matter experts
you should tap for review and for
productionizing this research?
Uh and if
you're having issues here, it probably
points to the stream issues, either in
uh how this research is being
coordinated and handing off, or perhaps
the code base that's hosting it.
Uh anyway, that's about all I've got. I
hope this is helpful.
I love uh thinking about ways
how our team can speed up how quickly we
can bring research concepts into
production. And if you made it this
whole way, you're probably interested in
that stuff, too. And I would love to
compare notes uh and trade ideas
anytime.